it's been almost nine months since apple
released the iphone 12 pro max and i
started using it
and today i want to do a follow-up real
world review
covering all the changes and fixes that
have happened in that time and believe
me there are a lot of them
and cover what is keeping me using this
device instead of a really great android
alternative and what's keeping me
trapped
but with that new issues that have come
up
and possibly defective issues with at
least
my iphone and maybe yours as well some
of these things have really surprised me
and i think they'll be great news for
you guys
as well and i'm just gonna focus on real
world things i'm gonna skip specs and
all of that
so let's get started and talk about the
design
and the durability i honestly have been
very
impressed i go caseless with my phones i
do use
a wallet i've recently switched over to
the moft one
which we didn't really do a review on
but this thing is fantastic it works as
a stand
it's easier to get your cards out it
fits one additional card compared to
apples
i love this thing but even without it
with this phone falling probably about
five to six
times the edges look so clean i have one
bump on one corner
and it's not even that noticeable one
thing that i've noticed
is that the gold stainless steel coating
is much more durable than before i have
very little
micro scratches and the same thing goes
on the back this coating right here is
very durable that could also be the
design the square edges that are helping
but overall i am very pleased and as far
as the front
no cracks anything like that now i do
have one crack a very unfortunate one
and it is right there on the main lens i
think that was just really poor
luck and that is something that you can
get swapped out by itself
you don't have to swap out the whole
back but other than that
durability has been awesome and as far
as the square edge design that was a
huge change for
apple i still am really digging it the
amount of grip that you have even
without a case
is really good the back is still slick
but overall it feels great in the hand
and i don't regret the change coming
from the previous round edge design and
since we touched on the cameras
let's go ahead and talk about what has
changed when apple announced this phone
they showed off the extra 2.5 x zoom
the sensor stabilization and people
wanted to buy the larger size
because of the extra camera benefits
that you couldn't get with the smaller
ones well
in our videos we showed off that the
quality wasn't that much
better and there were other downsides
for example
the extra sensor size causes warping for
close-up photos and you can't focus as
closely
that has been an issue for me and with
the telephoto lens the quality isn't
that much better
and it also can't focus as closely so
in this last nine months i really
haven't been using a telephoto camera as
much as i did
with the iphone 11 and i'm doing
portrait shots mainly with the main lens
now on top of that the competition has
gotten so good
both with similarly priced phones and
cheaper ones
where the quality looks great the
software is consistent
and they have other features such as the
telescopic cameras
where it can zoom in very close and
still get insane quality photos
you can shoot 8k video that actually
looks good now
and with the larger megapixel sensors
you can get much more detail and good
lighting so because of that
multiple times i've been tempted to just
go and switch to those
if i'm traveling somewhere and i want to
get the best photos from
a smartphone so overall i would just say
that
based on this and the updates they made
i've just been a little bit disappointed
and there's really not a big reason to
go with this higher end one and even
limitations compared to
previous iphone and now let's talk about
something that i'm just
really surprised by how much of a
difference it made in my everyday
life with the new iphone 12 pro max
and that is magsafe after nine months i
absolutely love it and that is one
reason why i haven't switched over to
this
because when you're traveling when you
have a charger when you have the car
mount
it's just so convenient to be able to
pop up your phone on your charger at
home like for example i have the three
in one
pop it off if you want to grab it in bed
pop it back on it charges
it works every time because it's aligned
with that gives you the ability to snap
a wallet there and have everything in
one pocket it's just been such a big
convenience to me that would be hard to
switch to anything
else and it really makes a difference in
convenience
day-to-day and now let's touch on
probably the biggest
advertised feature with the new iphones
another first for the iphone 12s and
that is
5g now right out of the gate the speeds
were so much faster
than the previous iphones it was
incredible and
also the reception was better so places
like my church where i got pretty much
no reception or super slow speeds
outside got much
faster honestly it has only gotten
better speeds have gotten faster
in other areas where i didn't previously
have coverage
with new updated 5g antennas and i'm
talking about not high band
super fast speed that kind of goes away
if you go around the corner i'm talking
about
mid-banded low band rural areas have
better coverage and i think this is
probably the same case
all across the us with all carriers
after nine months
it's better given another year it's
going to be even better now before we
cover
the biggest issue that i have with the
new iphone specifically
the 12 pro max that has not only been
irritating me like crazy last month
but actually cost me money let's talk
about another new piece of hardware that
has improved the iphone
within its lifespan that is the air tags
now of course these things can be used
with um any iphone with older iphones as
well but with the latest ones you get
the extra features such as the visual
navigation
and i have to say these things really
help apple's ecosystem and make it much
harder to go
from an iphone and switch over to
something like a samsung even though i
would like to
previously you had imessage you had the
apple watch but
now with mac safe and air tags this
phone is just
incredible they're cheap they work well
i have a bunch of them i have them on
objects such as my boat
so that if somebody steals it i can
actually find it's just hidden there
i have them in my bags and the greatest
thing that happened lately was with the
beta
ios 15 it will actually give you
notifications
if you leave not only air tags so if you
leave your keys
or something else your bag somewhere but
also things like your ipad and other
apple
accessories and that just makes it so
nice to use an
iphone compared to something else and
now for the biggest
issue that is making me literally want
to leave this phone
and just downgrade to an iphone 12 that
is the display
and it's not really an issue with the
display itself the display is beautiful
hdr video looks amazing on it manual
brightness when you turn it all the way
up is
great this is apple's best display but
my issue
is with this largest display for example
this display gets really bright but if
you start
gaming on it after not that long it will
dim and if you're outside gaming or in a
bright room that can be an
issue and that is actually something
that doesn't happen with the iphone 12
mini and it's much less of an issue with
the iphone 12.
now i think that is probably because of
the display being much larger
extra pixels and that means extra heat
and it is really becoming an issue
especially in the last month
we're out here in summer now it's
getting hotter and i'm having so many
issues for example when i'm driving in
my truck
and it's a hotter day i have it set up
on max if it's charging there
it's really nice to use but the screen
will end up dimming
and it'll dim so much so that it gets
kind of dark to see
and that's something that you wouldn't
have with other phones
and then with that i was using it last
weekend with my drone
and because of the sun and because it's
plugged in it got so
hot and warm that the screen was so dim
that i literally could barely see it
outside
and i was flying in a remote area but i
did end up crashing my drone
and the repair is about 400 bucks to get
that fixed
and i've been flying drones for eight to
ten years i don't crash
drones i'm very careful but the screen
just dimmed down
my drone was in the air and i couldn't
see it and luckily i was able to recover
it but
that is just such an annoying issue and
it's just frustrating enough and it's
happening often enough now that i'm
wondering
is the my iphone 12 pro max defective
or maybe other people are having that
issue as well you guys let me know down
in the comment
section and i think that's inexcusable
in this age
where other phones are having um they're
having graphite cooling
they're having vapor chamber cooling
it's a non-issue with high-end phones
but iphone's most expensive phone is
having this issue
much worse than their iphone 11 did and
now for something that
really surprised me lately and that is
longevity of
the battery i thought maybe my battery
is going bad maybe that's why i was
getting so hot and dimming
but i went into battery health and i'm
getting a solid
100 battery health whereas
this time last year my iphone 11 pro max
was probably around 92 91 and then at
the one
year mark when i switched to this one it
was at 88
and so far after nine months i'm still
at a hundred
now that is because apple added that
optimized charging feature which will
only charge it to eighty percent
and it'll finish last 20 right before
you need it and this just proves that
apple's
feature and update has really helped
this latest
iphone now overall as you guys heard
most things have been really positive
let me know your guys's thoughts if
you're somebody that bought one of these
phones or if you're somebody that wants
to buy one what your thoughts are
go and comment down below click that
circle to subscribe if you guys want to
help us reach a million subscribers
before the end of the year
thank you guys for watching this been
max and i'll see you in the next video